martin lévesque nous demande ce qu'il en
est du projet de loi 173 qui vise à
instaurer un revenu minimum garanti au
québec
est ce qu'il a été adopté la réponse et
8 martin ce projet de loi qui fait
partie d'un vaste plan de lutte contre
la pauvreté au québec qui a été adopté
par l'assemblée nationale au printemps
dernier cette mesure vise environ 84
1000 personnes qui présentent des
contraintes sévères à l'emploi et qui
sont prestataires du programme dette
sociale depuis 66 des soixante douze
derniers mois
concrètement comment ça se passe une
personne handicapée qui touche en ce
moment en 2018 l'aide sociale soit douze
mille 500 $ pourra toucher un revenu
minimum de 18 milles de là en 2023
cette personne d'ailleurs ne sera pas
pénalisée si par la suite elle reçoit un
héritage ou si elle se forme en ménage
cette mesure avait été chiffré par le
gouvernement libéral de philippe
couillard à 1,25 milliard de dollars
si vous avez d'autres questions sur
cette élection québécoise écrivez nous
vos élections à radio tirer canada.ca